Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab,
and today it's patient zero. Let's try subject. Yeah. And this next story, oh,
it's so huge. It's the ultimate patient zero story.
Really many of us have lived through this. It was, it's as recent an event.
It's, it's such a recent event that it still hurts and it still bleeds. Yeah.
And in it somewhere is a, literally the,
the patient that is called zero. So this was, yeah,
a lot of people are going to help us tell this story,
but starting us off is science writer, Radiolab, regular Carl Zimmer.
So in 1981
doctors for the first time described mysterious,
newly discovered disease syndrome, which affects mostly homosexual men.
The young men in Los Angeles are dying.
The number of cases has been growing faster and faster.
So far more than 80 Americans have died. 258 people have died.
625 people have died. Of course,
this is the part we all know how from those first few cases in La,
aids became one of the deadliest pandemics the world has ever seen.
More dangerous than the plague of the Middle Age.
In the back of the beginning there was a story that I have not been able to
shake for the last 30 years and it's a story I don't want to reimagine right
now.
[inaudible]
right after news of this syndrome started to break that science writer,
David [inaudible], who along with Carl will be one of our guides.
Epidemiologists were trying to figure out where did it come from and they were
thinking like, well, maybe it's a sexually transmitted disease.
So the CDC launches a study of a group of about 30 patients,
gay men in New York, Los Angeles,
and San Francisco to see who had had sexual contact with whom.
How do you get to us that just a series of interviews with people. Yeah,
please name all the people that you, that you've slept with.
The CDC eventually releases the results of this survey in the form of a diagram
like a network drawing with circles representing patients in lines representing
sexual contact and each patient,
each little circle was numbered New York seven Los Angeles 12 so you didn't know
who was who, but you could tell immediately when you look at
this thing that of all the 30 or so circles,
there was one circle that was special.
It had lines coming out in every direction,
seven or eight emanating from him like the hub of a wheel except all the spokes
on this wheel connected to other wheels which then shot out and connected to
other wheels fanning outward at the center of it all was that one little circle.
Cool numbered zero number zero as far as we know,
that was the first time that you ever get the term patient zero.
Patient zero was on. I am the central victim and victimizer.
This is from a 60 minutes special. In 1988 that year,
a reporter named Randy Schultz had written a book called and the band played on
that for the first time revealed the identity of patient zero.
He was a French Canadian and very handsome airline steward, name gates,
[inaudible] gates, and [inaudible] zero. A few minutes later in
the report, Schultes comes on to describe I've guy
who has got [inaudible]
limited sexual stamina.
This sexual athlete who would fly from one hot spot to the next because of his
job having sex with literally thousands of men on his,
he knew he was dying, at least according to Randy Schultz,
he became somewhat sinister and malicious.
He would sleep with a male partner at a bathhouse in San Francisco or somewhere
else, and then when the light came up, according to Randy Shilts, he would say,
I've got gay cancer
now. You're going to get it to your doctor. I talked to him. Yeah.
This is Dr Selma dreads. She was part of that CDC. Yes.
I told him that he was getting other people sick with it and he said,
my rights to do whatever I want by civil rights.
I do as I please. I've got it. Why shouldn't they have it? They said,
you can kill yourself. You wanted,
you got no right to take somebody else along with you. And you said screw you.
And walked out.
Really a chilling moment.
[inaudible]
and pretty much from that moment on Gayton UGA, he just took on this,
this aura as a single handedly causing a, a,
an epidemic in the United States. Now, I don't know about you,
but I first bumped into this story in the movie version of,
in the band played on my friend would talking about thousands of men whose faces
I cannot even remember. And you want name that's an actor playing gait,
new gun movie. Now,
when I first saw that aids had already infected two and a half million people,
and to think that it could all go back to this one guy just seemed unreal.
It was a, it was a very, uh, potent story. There's no doubt
[inaudible]
and, and he gave HIV to a lot of people. There's no question about that.
But what we do know is that he was not patient zero.
He was not patients there. No, he was not the beginning point.
He was not even close. Huh.
So here's the question that got me started in the story. Yeah. Okay.
So the gay steward, that was the movie stuck in my head.
But what's the real movie?
What movie can we make about the beginning of the AIDS epidemic?
Because when you've got something so vast that according to some mass mints will
have killed 60 million people by the end of the decade.
What you need a beginning.
You need some way of explaining how this disaster happened and how it might
happen again.
And how exactly do we know that Gayton Duco wasn't patient's euro? Well, um,
there are a couple of reasons we know it. So, um,
so one thing that people started to do, scientists was to, um,
they went, started going back and looking at people who had died,
who died mysteriously aids, like things in the past might,
some of them have been early cases and they started finding a lot.
Robert Rayford had aids 12 years before it was recognized in this country.
In 1959 a sailor in Britain died of pneumonia.
And so for awhile you had all these new patients. Zero
in 1961 a nurse in Chicago died of Kappa Sarcoma,
but the real definitive blow to this.
So patient zero nonsense came by actually looking at the virus itself
in 1984, same year that gate unto God died.
Scientists isolate the virus HIV,
which is really just a little string of genetic code that gets into your body
and into your cells and uses your cells to make copies of itself.
But here's the thing,
when it replicates within a single patient, it copies itself. Um,
in precisely,
it mutates quickly.
It changes a lot as the virus duplicates itself inside a person,
the dukes often have little copying errors and then little mutations,
it turns out those errors, they happen at a predictable rate.
You can kind of almost predict how many you're going to see in a year or five
years. And so the amount of changes that you see out there,
the diversity really of the viruses in the aids population.
Well that becomes really good information.
And so a group of scientists began to look at the amount of diversity among HIV
patients in the u s and other parts of the world.
And the more diversity the longer the virus has been around. Right, right.
And they could use that kind of like a clock.
If you have a virus here and a virus there,
you could measure how different they are and you would know that it would take a
certain amount of time for them to get that different.
And to make a long story short,
the picture they get is that aids entered the United States around 1966
at a time when Gayton to God was still a virgin adolescent.
From there,
scientists were able to trace the virus back to Haiti and from Haiti back to
Africa.
It's been there the longest. It's had the longest time to become diverse,
to mutate, to evolve. So if you want to really, if you want to get to the,
to the real patients, your as it were,
the most interesting staff come actually comes from Africa.
So one way to try to figure out its origins there is to go looking for the
virus.
Yup.
And that takes us back to Zr 59 and DRC 60 can we talk about them?
Sure.
What these are the two earliest known HIV positive human specimens,
and this is where, for me at least,
the story gets way bigger than I imagined from no.
The first sample zr 59 came to light in the late nineties somehow scientists
unearthed a very old tube of blood from a hospital in Kinshasa in the Democratic
Republic of Congo and when they tested it,
it had HIV.
This had been taken from a band to man in 1959 1959 right?
Yeah. Nobody knows his name.
Nobody even knows I think what he died of and that was the only one for a number
of years. That was our one glimpse
into the kind of deep history of HIV.
But then along comes that Guy Michael Warby.
He's an evolutionary biologist at the University of Arizona and a few years ago
Michael went back to Kinshasa and found a second sample.
He actually found the virus lurking in a tiny bit of human tissue that was
preserved in paraffin wax. It's kind of like a Hans Solo in,
uh,
in the star wars movie when he's kind of frozen in that carbonite or whatever
that stuff is. And this new sample, it was from the same town.
Kinshasa is the first and also more importantly from the same time,
1960 and with the two of them then you can kind of go back in time.
And so yes, like we described before,
you can measure the differences between the samples,
calculate how long it would take for those samples to get that different.
And in the end you can use these two samples to wind the clock all the way back
to the virus.
It started at all and it turned out the most recent common ancestor of those two
specimens goes back to two, about 1908,
1908. That is when it started in human beings.
What 1908 77 well roughly give or take a margin of error early 19 hundreds.
Wow. So around 1908 give or take,
something happened. That's right.
That moment is the spillover spill over spillovers the term the scientists use
to describe the moment when a virus in one species passes into another species.
New Diseases in humans tend to pop up from animals.
So people said, okay, flu comes from birds. Where does HIV come from to get it?
Then answer, you have to look beyond human beings.
You have to look at other viruses that are like HIV.
So the search was on the inability to find a similar disease and research animal
turns out right about the time that the HIV virus was discovered.
Scientists at the New England primate research center,
some researchers found a virus like it in the CAC monkey monkey. In fact,
it was so similar that they called it
Sib Simian immunodeficiency virus. Yes.
And that's where the origin quest started. This is Beatrice Han.
I'm a professor of medicine and microbiology at the University of Pennsylvania.
And so after they found it, macaques, what happened? Um,
it took a couple of years,
but eventually she says they found Siv instill another primate species to sooty.
Mangabey and then in a few more African green monkeys mandrill pretty soon it
was all over the place.
Now I think 40 different species of African monkeys known to have their own
version of Siv. So then the question was,
which one of these monkeys or primates pass it to us? Then unexpectedly,
a researcher named Martine Martine Peters at the center in Gabon decided to test
her chimps who? Orphan chimpanzees and Bingo.
She found a very, very close match,
a virus that was the closest relative of HIV one. So everybody said, well,
you know,
it was a gym. It was a gym. Okay, yeah, it came from chimp. Yes.
But then the question was, well, which chimps or rather where,
where exactly.
So Beatrice Hahn and her colleagues started looking at chimps that came
different parts
of western Central Africa.
Now getting blood samples from chimps in the wild is pretty much,
it just isn't feasible, you know,
because in the wild they hide the moment they see us. So you,
you get stuck with fecal samples, poop? Oh yes.
There's lots of DNA in there and viruses.
So they would just go to where the chimpanzees would sleep at night and they
would just, you know, collect some poop, bring it back to the lab,
and Beatrice would analyze all the viruses over 90 different wild communities
from every part of central Africa, over 7,000 different fecal samples,
and slowly they were able to piece together which communities were infected in
which ones had the closest HIV one. That's when it hit us
first time.
What exactly hit you that geographic origin of these chimps in 2006 her and her
colleagues published at the human aids virus comes from a group of chimps,
a very specific group that live in a very specific place.
This little corner of southeastern camera between the Bloomberg River and Goco
river and the Sanga River.
These chimps were essentially penned in between these three rivers
scenario. Probably only have a hundred square miles. Not much more than that.
Wow.
When we're looking at what humans have and we're looking at what all of those
chimps in Africa have,
the most perfect match is this little territory up there in Cameron.
Yeah. There is no other virus that is any closer. So that's that.
So can you reconstruct the spillover and the WHO that it spilled over into as
best, you know, as best as [inaudible]
you can understand, it can hypothesize.
And the best hypothesis is the cut hunter hypothesis.
The cut hunter, the cut hunter. That's right. A hunter who gets cut.
And what can we say about this guy? I mean as you, what do we know about it?
If we had to guess,
if we had to guess that human was probably a band to man living very near the
forest or in the forest and southeastern Cameroon,
he was hunting.
Maybe he had a bow and Arrow, maybe he had a spear
and uh,
kills the champions.
Bingo. Here's a big pile of me and he starts to put your head,
he's cutting open the chest cavity. He's pulling out organs and
he cuts himself and he gets blood to blood contact chimpanzee blood against his
blood.
What happens is that the virus in the chimpanzee blood found itself in an
environment that was unexpected, that was alien to it,
but was not too much different from the biochemical environment.
It had been in chimpanzee blood.
It could function and that's the moment.
That's the moment it begins that human is patient zero.
The why then
why 1908 I mean presumably people have been hunting ships for a really long
time. Why wouldn't this guy be patient 7 million?
That's another of the big questions.
People certainly in in central Africa have been eating monkeys
for thousands of years. I mean, David says there's really no way to know,
but this could have just been the right virus. Maybe
a particular virus evolved in a way that made it more transmissible in humans
or maybe it just got lucky to come along at precisely the right time.
What you're looking at this is Carl again,
is a time when this part of Africa was being heavily colonized.
The French and the Belgians were building trained systems.
The populations were on the move can Shaza which was then Leopoldville.
It was exploding. It was huge.
The cities were attracting people from the boonies in those days.
So by 1908,
all the virus has to do is get from that tiny village where the cut hunter lived
to one of the new cities. That happens almost certainly by river
[inaudible].
I was stirred by the work of Beatrice on and Mike Warby to see what this
scenario looked like on the ground
[inaudible]
so I went to southeastern camera and,
and I chartered a little boat about a 30 foot wooden boat with an outboard
motor, any trace, the path of the virus.
We went down the and Goco river and we stopped at a few villages.
There are a couple of little villages there,
one of which has a market where you can buy um,
monkey meat and crocodile meat.
And he says it wasn't hard to imagine how it all might've went down.
Perhaps the cut hunter gave the virus to a woman who then passed it on to a
fisherman fellow that I called the voyager
who then gotten a boat is David did
and carried it down the river. Sanga River, which is the Goco,
is a tributary of the Sanga. Sanga becomes a bigger river 200 meters wide,
which then flows to the Congo river, the big river, and into the city.
And I imagine him sliding into Brazzaville
around 1920 the first HIV positive man to arrive an urban center where there's
much greater density of humans, where there are prostitutes,
a greater fluidity of social and sexual interactions.
And that seems to have been the place from which the disease went global.
So that's how it happened.
[inaudible]
we can take it back even farther actually. What do you mean
all right guys, if you want to make a movie about this start of it. Well,
this is not the start
because we got it from chimps. Right? Right.
So you could ask her who was chimp's zero, what do we know about chimps? Zero,
right? Yeah. I mean everything comes from somewhere. And again,
by molecular work scientists have been able to determine that the chimp fires is
actually, it actually comes from two monkey viruses,
two different monkeys from two completely different species.
What would they have encountered each other somewhere or had a fight?
Uh, they probably encountered each other in the stomach of a chimp.
[inaudible]
meaning what? Well, from the perspective of a chimpanzee monkeys,
they look tasty. This is Nathan Wolfe,
professor and human biology at Stanford University. And he says,
to fully understand this part of the patient,
you're a rather chimp zero narrative.
You have to grasp how it is that chimps hunt.
And this is something he witnessed in the Kabale national forest in,
in southwestern Uganda.
Describe to US watching three male chimps converge on a tree.
Fourth call this monkeys, which are those really small black and white.
And one individual managed to grab two juvenile.
And then the three individuals all met up and
began to,
the monkey was still alive. The chimpanzee was going after, uh, an Oregon,
you know, that that obviously was a tasty morsel that, that he was going after.
And, and the monkey was, uh, was screaming bloody murder.
It is quite disturbing to watch, he says, but the,
one of the things that struck me at that moment
was the depth of contact between the blood.
And Body fluids of this monkey and the chimpanzee.
The chimps are literally covered in blood and blood on their face,
in their eyes and from the virus perspective.
This is spillover heaven. Okay,
so the following is the closest that we can get to a zero point in this entire
narrative. We don't know where it happened and we don't know exactly the time.
Say some hundreds of thousands of years ago from the molecular clock.
We know it was less than a million years. That's all we know.
But whenever it was chimps,
zero was hunting and he comes upon a monkey called a red cap.
Mangabey the red Cap Mangabey. This is a,
a larger primate and these are tree dwelling. A little little guy tree dwelling,
a little bit of red for on their heads. Yes. Chips, zero spots.
One of these monkeys eats it
and then the process key catches a red cap mangabey version of the AIDS virus.
Next, sometime after that first kill weeks,
months, we don't know, maybe it was the same day.
Chimp zero comes across another monkey and this monkey was called a spot.
Knows Quentin. Yes, it's got a spot, its nose, I assume. There you go.
Very small.
One of the tiniest monkeys of all of the old world monkeys and chips,
zero eats that monkey and gets a spot nosed Guinen version of the AIDS virus for
the HIV virus inside.
So you've got the Red Cap Mangabey and you've got the spot.
Knows Gwen who've got a [inaudible] and a Mangabey,
two completely different kinds of Siv viruses inside the same chimp. Now,
under normal circumstances, according to Nathan,
both of these Siv viruses would go nowhere because one,
one of these viruses makes the jump.
They go from a place they've adapted to and that they know to a completely
foreign landscape like a human being dropped off on Mars,
maybe without a space suit.
I mean they basically are entering a completely alien habitat.
The cells don't look the same.
The environment is different and the chimps immune system would normally kill
them, but then once in a blue moon, something crazy happens.
These two viruses will end up inside the same cell, in the same chip.
At the same time,
literally there is a single cell simultaneously infected with both viruses to
suppose on one side of the cell you've got the Mangabey virus
[inaudible]
and on the other side of the same cell you've got the spot nose Gwen and virus.
And what happens is, uh, literally inside the cell you have an enzyme,
it's called the polymerase enzyme that's copying genetic information to the
virus. This is what viruses do.
They hijack these enzymes to make copies of themselves.
No,
here's the problem. These, these enzymes,
they're not necessarily that sticky and while they're in the process of copying
one virus, every once in awhile they'll accidentally fall off,
make copy and go black and latched on to the second virus and just keep on
copying. And so what it ends up spitting out is a hybrid
that
no, this new mosaic probably won't go anywhere because
99.999999999% of the time when these hybrids happens, dead end,
the chimps immune system is pretty sophisticated.
It has evolved defenses against these viruses and it will destroy them.
But again, once in a blue moon. So this is a blue moon after a blue moon,
after a blue moon to really get this.
Finally you get one particular mosaic virus
[inaudible]
we in the main could be in the quad and that through sheer random luck,
it landed on the exact right combination of genes that allowed it to evade the
chimp's immune system. I mean,
one of the amazing things to think about is how many,
how many hopeful monsters you had to have in order to get that one that actually
probably trillions, boom.
Suddenly in a flash from these two viruses that can barely survive in the chimp,
you get a new virus,
it's a little bit Mangabey, little bit in cannot only survive in the chimp,
but can thrive. In fact, for this baby virus,
the chimp is the perfect host and that was the virus that ended up spreading,
jumping over into humans.
And it's been this massive and incredibly traumatic sort of tear in the fabric
of humanity.
Uh,
let me add another parentheses.
There are essentially 12 major groups of the HIV virus.
What David means is it 12 different kinds of HIV?
Viruses have spilled over 12 different times.
Eight of them came from monkeys,
three of them came from chimps and one came from gorillas. Wow.
And of those 12 only one of them is responsible for the global pandemic.
There are 12 kinds, 12 times that we know about.
That's probably happened dozens and dozens more times that we don't know about.
So the spillover is not a highly improbable event.
These sorts of viruses, they're constantly paying at us.
They're pinging at us and pinging it at us. We see it happening all the time.
You see it happening all the time.
Nathan has set up a series of monitoring stations in places like central Africa
and he and his colleagues have been tracking what he calls the viral chatter in
the people who hunt these primates.
We collected specimens from the animals that they were hunting.
They compare that to blood samples from the hunters themselves. And guess what?
We found a whole range of new retroviruses that we're moving over into these
hunters. For example,
he's been tracking something called the Simian foamy virus,
which is first in the same family as HIV.
And he has seen it hot from an individual gorilla to an individual human who
killed that gorilla. Yeah.
These are almost certainly what we call primary transmission events. Oh,
says you really are looking at the potential beginning of something. Yes,
you want a patient zero and really clear patient zero. Uh,
it's some of these individuals that have been affected with these viruses.
And the real question is, how do we stop patients heroes?
How do, how do we avoid patient, the patient one and patient two. Exactly.
So Nathan is developing a series of tools like digital surveillance. I mean,
some of these places, uh,
I work in some places in Democratic Republic of Congo.
You basically have to fly in to get there. No roads, often, no electricity
[inaudible]
but many of these places, they still have cell phone towers.
So Nathan has begun to track cell phone call patterns in these communities.
So if he sees a blip of many calls to a medical center within a short period of
time, okay, boom.
Now we've got to investigate that and we continue to find that are
completely novel and we're looking to determine if these are,
if these are the next HIV cause anybody that says HIV landed in humans in 1908,
but we didn't know about it until 1981.
We had decades of time when this was a virus before it spread globally.
What if we'd been looking for it?
[inaudible]
a lot of people to thank for this segment,
thanks to Nathan Wolf for being Nathan and he has an awesome new book called the
viral storm.
Also thank you to Carl Zimmer whose book on viruses is called a planet of
viruses and thank you also to him and to Michael Worby. Uh,
their interview was recorded on a podcast from meet the scientist,
which you can find at microbe world [inaudible] dot org and thanks to David
Coleman, who's got a book called spillover coming out very soon,
which is all about diseases crossing over from animals to us and also to
Beatrice Han at the University of Pennsylvania and to Katie Slocombe from the
University of York for letting us use her recordings of chimpanzees.